China has reported a new record high of
covid-19 infections of more than 31 000
cases the highest since the virus was
first detected in Wuhan in late 2019.
cities across the country are expanding
lockdowns despite recent Announcement by
Beijing to scale back its zero covid
policy
in the central manufacturing Hub zhangju
zero covet fatigue and paid disputes
have kicked off violent protests among
workers at foxconn's vast iPhone Factory
they've been undercovered restrictions
for weeks but there will be no relief
yet on Thursday 6 million people in
parts of zhangju were told to stay at
home for five days and undergo Mass
testing
for more let's go across the
correspondent Fabian gretchma in Beijing
Fabian Chinese authorities had promised
more targeted measures as part of this
zero covet policy do these current
city-wide lockdowns feel different than
what people have so far experienced
well if so only slightly um yeah you
could argue that now
um the lockdowns are a little bit more
targeted for example here in Beijing at
least some parts of the population can
still go out can go on the street that's
um better than compared with a lockdown
in Shanghai this spring but uh yeah if
you go out then basically all shops are
closed schools are closed so the bigger
picture I would say is quite similar
we're back in lockdowns and um yeah also
caught up in this endless cycle of yeah
Mass testing quarantine and lockdowns
and we therefore see images of Foxconn
workers clashing with Riot police in the
city of zhangju have Chinese people
reach their limit with the zero covert
policy
yeah I mean the frustration the anger is
increasing uh actually massively
increasing interestingly it's not so
much the the protest in Zhengzhou that
the people are talking about because of
the heavy censorship the biggest
eye-opener the wake-up call for many
Chinese is interestingly the World Cup
in Qatar the football World Cup because
if you watch it on your TV from China
it's really a very surreal experience
um uh your many of us are in lockdown
here and some of us cannot go out on the
street and then you watch on the screen
you see crowded stadiums you see
cheering fans um a lot of people without
masks and um so people began to wander
and began begin to ask questions why are
we still caught up in this situation
where the rest of the world seems to
have learned to live with the virus I
mean this information that they get is
basically contradicting the propaganda
that always said that you know China is
controlling the virus while it spreads
out of control in the rest of the world
and we are basically the only country
that achieved success so many angry
users they posted on weibo on their
social media platforms and began to ask
a critical questions
it's a question that I've been asking
you as well in the conversations that
we've had because China had promised a
relaxation in the zero covet policy yet
we are seeing these city-wide lockdowns
is it a case of implementation up to
local officials they decide how severe a
lockdown is
but to some degree it's true that the
more on the ground the more local you
get the stricter is the implementation
that has to do with the fear of people
of the authorities to cause problems um
towards their bosses but I would say by
now it's quite clear that also the
central government does not want an
opening up
um today
um they send out a statement via the
office official news agency xinhua
saying that our new rules uh the
quote-unquote optimization of covet
rules doesn't mean that we will do
nothing that we will let the virus
spread so it was really kind of a
correction um and what it caused was
really a lot of misunderstanding a lot
of confusion nobody really knows exactly
where the way is going but now it should
actually be clear we are back to
lockdowns and zero Kobe zero covet will
be
um yeah implemented as before actually
large parts of Beijing have also entered
the lockdown Fabia and the City where
you are what is it like being in Beijing
right now
yeah it's quite depressing actually um
you know every day there are new several
hundreds of residential buildings that
are getting sealed off
um many of us don't know whether we wake
up tomorrow and then you know find a
lock in front of our doors or not
um they are really very horrible stories
people worry that what happens if I have
a medical emergency and but cannot go
out to the hospital another Chinese
woman in her mid-20s she told me that
she is now in a quarantine Center
because she tested positive for the
virus but
um before the health workers came to
transfer her she immediately took all
the cat food she had in her home and
spread it on the floor because she has
two cats and she's just hoping now that
the cats Will Survive the time her being
in a quarantine Center because she
doesn't know when she can get back home
and her building is sealed off her flat
is sealed off and I mean those are the
problems that many of us have to worry
about and as it seems it will not get
better in the next two days
if I'm going to crash my we'll leave it
there thanks so much for joining us